c'est en fait déjà si j'ai pas du tout
l'habitude c'est mon premier film donc
forcément je suis surprise et en plus
apparemment
du coup je sais pas comment ça
fonctionne d'habitude mais apparemment
c'est un succès incroyable sens à tout
ça donc oui je suis toujours très très
surprise et très très heureuse
c'est assez étrange en fait parce que au
moment où j'ai été nominée
j'étais dans une voiture avec des
animateurs d'une radio du nord qui me
ramenait à la gare et
mon téléphone sonne c'est mon agent je
réponds et là il me fais tu as été voir
twitter n'ont été nominé est en fait
j'avais complètement oublié que c'était
ce jour-là goût il sortait les nominés
et du coup j'ai créé voilà